I used to think about it as,
you could take care of your health,
or you could take care of obligations,
and one always came at the cost of the other.
So now, several hundred of these walking meetings later,
I've learned a few things.
First, there's this amazing thing
about actually getting out of the box
that leads to out-of-the-box thinking.
Whether it's nature or the exercise itself, it certainly works.
And second, and probably the more reflective one,
is just about how much each of us
can hold problems in opposition
when they're really not that way.
And if we're going to solve problems
and look at the world really differently,
whether it's in governance or business
or environmental issues, job creation,
maybe we can think about how to reframe those problems
as having both things be true.
Because it was when that happened
with this walk-and-talk idea
that things became doable and sustainable and viable.
So I started this talk talking about the tush,
so I'll end with the bottom line, which is,
walk and talk.
Walk the talk.
You'll be surprised at how fresh air drives fresh thinking,
and in the way that you do,
you'll bring into your life an entirely new set of ideas.
Thank you.
(Applause)